at the core of this series what really
exists is a love story yeah and all the
beautiful elements of a classic Love
Story hello do you trust me which is
something that you don't expect for a
show called Dr Death that that's what
comes out the most beautiful love story
and the show is called Dr
Death hi everyone I'm Mandy Moore and
I'm Edgar Ramirez from the peup original
series Dr Death okay so today we're
going to talk about what it's like to
film season 2 are you ready yeah let's
go when don't you come with me to Russia
to Moscow I just remember from my
character's perspective that this was
such a Monumental Turning Point Al this
is a moment where he's also kind of like
doing a like a power show bringing
Bonita to to Russia and he really enjoys
the mystery to always like living kind
of like this
very yeah red crumbs like planting this
clues for you to this cover it's the
first time in their relationship they're
still very much under wraps and trying
to keep their relationship sort of
covert and this is the first time
there's any semblance of Freedom they're
all the way in Russia and like feel like
they can actually feel free to be
themselves and be happy and in love and
not have to hide anything from anybody
all the while I think she's sort of
silently struggling with her own pain
hey hey hey hey I just remember being a
lot of choreography of like where the
camera was go where you were going to go
cuz once we get into the hotel room and
like all bets are off and Bonita's like
in abject pain and apulo has to sort of
just like get down to it and knows that
he has to like perform this quas surgery
it is all about precision and I felt
like that was like very Monumental in
this particular scene and then
everything got smaller smaller smaller
as we walked in do you trust
[Applause]
me yeah and also we had special effects
yep it was fun cuz it was so gross yeah
it was so gross but again when it comes
to like those sort of special effects
there's so much choreography and it has
to be so intentional and so precise that
like it is challenging it's a long day
it was a long day the minute they said
caught you're going to be fine trust
me it was a dream to work with you on
this show I mean we understood each
other right away lots of conversations
like ready to run lines very on yeah
yeah yeah it was so much fun considering
it was such a heavy subject matter for
me like I just had the pleasure of like
falling in love like he's so charming
and winning it's like I was tasked with
something very easy in that sense I
remember that conversation outside in
New York about the Beatles And The
Rolling Stones I love that scene
remember like we should do a romantic
it's true and yeah and then we need to
we need to get back to that yeah yeah
yeah we totally left that night wanted
to find a romantic comedy to do together
in the most classic yeah way right it
was so easy to do it with you it was so
easy to fall in love too
like it could cost me my job but I think
this thing we have it's worth the risk
for me too watch Dr D season 2 only on
peacock and that's a
wrap